so behaving badly let's talk about the
film and how you booked your role yeah
they even badly is a comedy and it comes
to theaters August first and I'm going
to the premiere on Tuesday it's with
selena gomez nat wolff Elizabeth Schumer
Louise Parker dylan mcdermott Patrick
Warburton I mean it's just decently it's
just it Heather Graham and everybody
else it's like one of those you know
laundry list of just like it's a comedy
kind of like a screwball Ferris
Bueller's Day Off type of thing is how I
describe it and how it's been described
what's it about yeah um it is I always
try to go how could I sum this up
because there's so many different side
stories you know that are happening with
all the different characters oh and Gary
Busey um uh it is veldt Nina Pennington
is the the role that Selena Gomez plays
and NAT Wolf's character falls in love
you know it's crazy about her I'll
dreamy about her they're in high school
and basically it's him doing whatever he
can and whatever it takes to get the
girl even if it means running in Somalia
and strippers and you know it's like all
these different crazy things and CEO in
order to get her attention so in your
character is Janice um I Janice uh it
was written originally as Patrick
Warburton's character is principal pool
and so I play his secretary and high
school and then actually this was pretty
cool after they did the first round of
kind of showing the film to what is it
called test audience test audiences they
said that they really liked me and
wanted to see more of me cuz i had a
small role at first so they changed the
ending from like selena gomez and nat
wolff kissing and having it be like a
lovey-dovey thing to it going back to
being silly again and so they wrote this
whole ending so Janice principal's
secretary by day and at night I'm Janice
at um Heather Graham's a strip club and
I'm like an MC there so and so how did
you
who even hear about the role oh my agent
called me it was really last minute to
remember I was like on this side of town
east side and he said can you get down
to two casting and all the way in Santa
Monica just like an hour you know it
takes like it can you get there now I
must in either side to be perfect for
this you know it's my Louise Parker
comedy I was like are you kidding me and
ran out of here just me was looking at
it on the way try thing yeah and said
that I booked it okay yeah did you have
a call back or you just on the spot um
they had producers and they also did it
on camera so they had that to look at
and so yeah they said it was their first
choice so that's always a good thing so
then once you booked at how soon before
you were actually filming oh I'm not
sure I think I might have been a month
I'm not totally sure yeah and how many
days were you on set um like just like
three days three days okay so your
character sounds like she's spunky like
by day she's more composed yeah at night
she's a little more spunky yeah so how
did you do you had time to sort of run
lines with people what did you do yeah
it was crazy because they kept they kept
changing the script and I had a shoot
date so say it was you know wednesday at
you know 5am and here i was like Monday
night we're still changing it and get a
couple changes and then they switched it
to having Heather Graham like after I've
been working on it and they were like I
think we're gonna have Heather Graham do
it like that she would be the emcee at
her club you know like by day she's an
attorney and by night I was like are you
kidding me it's like well I guess this
is a good problem if it's like between
me and Heather Graham like okay I'm
gonna say that you know but uh ya know
so they kept changing it back until the
night before and finally got the script
and then Tim Derek the actor I mean the
director awesome guy he let us improvise
on top of the script and the writers
were always around and the producers
were always around so you know we kept
it based on the script that was written
but then he got
you know we got to play and what was
your call time that first day crack of
dawn at 6am did you sleep the night
before s sort of it's sort of not so how
is that going in because it means a lot
to you yeah you have to be up early you
know you have to sort of be on your game
and perky and everything yeah then
you're dealing with that lack of sleep
and that oh I think I was just like I
was so excited that I can you know run
on those kind of fumes but I did get I
did feel pretty nervous when they showed
me my trailer and they're standing like
Gary Vee and Heather crayon and I'm like
looking around and I did kind of like go
oh my gosh i need the braid it didn't go
i get my trailer for a minute um yeah
cuz you had one of these moments where
you kind of to pinch me I just got
nervous yeah the sudden it was just a
brush of oh my gosh I better not mess
this up type of a thing so you get on
set yeah and it's yours and then it's
fine like once I'm like it's kind of
like the waiting room and the prep and
stuff that gets me like nervous and the
chitchat and stuff like I just kind of
want to do it so yeah so it was three
days and then once you wrapped were
there any pickup shots they needed from
you or yeah there was time between when
they did the test audiences and came
back and said we're writing this role
for you but I can't really remember if
it was a couple months and then they had
like a wrap party what was this rule
harder for you than anything else or
were there other roles that are actually
harder this was just more exciting oh
this is just fun yeah yeah
you